there's some other video coming out of
shanghai china right now that is
absolutely insane and i really thought
about whether i wanted to show this
video or not because it's so profoundly
evil what's happening there and i don't
want to be alarmist
but i think it's important to know what
happens when a fully authoritarian
government uh what full fascism
which is what they're trying to usher in
here
communism marxism i don't even care what
you call it at this point when full
government control over the people is
allowed uh here's what's happening this
is a compilation video uh of what's
happening right now in china over what
they're saying is now the next version
of omicron
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay you're seeing a whole bunch of
different stuff in that compilation
you're seeing a child that that first
video was a child who had been separated
from his parents from what i understand
just wandering around trying to find
some assistance the screaming that you
were hearing those were in buildings in
shanghai those are people who have been
locked in their apartments they no
longer have food in many cases they
don't have running water they are
literally starving to death people are
dying in their apartments there are
other videos we didn't want to show you
people are jumping from their windows
because they are sick of starving to
death because the government has decided
that they should have a zero-covet
policy this is only because people
allowed the government to have too much
power over their lives and governments
do horrible things it's just a sick
twisted part of humanity it just is
um so and then of course what you're
seeing there is rioting related to food
and and a whole bunch more okay so what
was the point of today's show the point
of today's show is there is a way to
stop this and we can do it
we cannot burn this country we can
choose not to burn this country but the
sane liberals the moderate democrats you
might be the key to this whole thing and
i don't know how many of you watch this
show anymore i i suspect a bunch of you
do well i know a bunch of you do but i
think you have to start speaking up you
might be the key to this whole thing the
conservatives the libertarians
whatever they they basically get it we
know which way they're going to vote and
we know that a lot of people are
shifting that way right here in florida
alone when desantis came in uh there
were about 200 000 more registered
democrats than republicans last i heard
there's about 90 000 more registered
republicans than democrats we're going
to see this happen we saw what happened
in virginia with yunkan okay but the key
at a national level if this country is
to continue is that if you are a decent
democrat if you are a decent liberal if
you are bill maher you can no longer
vote for people
who are destroying the ideas that you
purport to believe in you cannot vote
for democrats anymore you do not have to
be a republican but you cannot be a
democrat it's not that hard this is not
rocket science we have to save this
country we have to do it right now the
democratic party must be destroyed we
must get rid of all of them we don't
have to jail them we don't have to ban
them we don't have to put them in gulags
but we have to get them out of power and
we have to put the power back in the
hands of the people that's what we have
to do and now in summation how do we do
that
it's actually quite simple
good people must just stand up the
individual must stand up and say here i
am and this is what i believe in and i
will not give power to people who do not
deserve it